looking at a list of the largest
religions in the world the top results
are often very old stemming back
thousands of years
christianity islam hinduism buddhism are
all traditions that have been here for
quite a moment but then there is sikhism
which is often listed as the fifth
largest religious group in the world and
yet it is a rather young religion
especially compared to the other ones on
the list
having origins in 16th century punjab in
india sikhs have established themselves
as a major faith tradition around the
world and are often very recognizable
sadly one of the reasons for this is
that they have often been mistaken for
muslims due to their appearance and have
received a certain
discrimination as a result to anyone
watching it should be clear that all of
these kinds of misunderstandings are due
to a lack of information and lack of
education about the sikh religion which
is exactly why it is appropriate to make
this video so who are the six and what
are their beliefs and their practices
[Music]
sikhism is a monotheistic religious
tradition with origins in india and with
the punjab as its sort of base or
central region
what we refer to as sikhism is actually
called sikhi by its practitioners and
this is a rather important point the way
we look at the world of religions as
just that a group of fixed religions
with defined borders and categorizations
is very much a western invention a
result of colonialist paradigms and
techniques of ruling thus we often see
in places like india how traditions that
are very complex and function and
organize themselves in very different
ways than in europe how they are
religionized here in the west we have a
certain idea of what a religion is which
is almost exclusively based on a
christian model in particular and when
the colonial powers for example wish to
categorize their the people that they
ruled in terms of religion they did so
based on this christian model complex
and nuanced local native traditions
became isms like hinduism buddhism and
sikhism and to be a religion based on
the christian model meant that you had
certain things you had a founder you had
a book and you had certain beliefs and
practices that characterized your
religion but when it comes to the
religions of india like sikhism for
example things were often a lot more
complex than that and to apply a already
fixed christian model to these
traditions in india does not really
capture their complexity and the actual
way that these traditions worked
historically so this should be kept in
mind as we go forward i will
occasionally be using the word sikhism
but and when we do so we should
understand that this is a construct and
that it doesn't really capture the
complexity and vibrance of the tradition
of sikhi the word sikhi is related to
the punjabi word sikna which means to
learn so sikhi and to be a sikh
essentially means to be on a path of
learning a path of self-purification and
devotion specifically to a group of
teachers known as the gurus
who are these gurus then well
let's get started
sikhism was essentially founded or at
least originates in the life and
teachings of the first guru guru nanak
as well as a succeeding line of nine
gurus following him guru nanak was born
in 1469 in a village close to lahore
his family were of the hindu tradition
and at a young age he received education
in the vedas and the so-called six
schools of hindu philosophy but
biographies also tell of how he studied
some persian and arabic with muslims and
that none of the traditions and wisdoms
he was taught seemed satisfactory to him
from a very early age nanak showcased
unusual behavior he became very
spiritually inclined and was entirely
uninterested in mundane affairs which
worried his parents who desperately
wanted him to get married and have a
normal job i think a lot of us can
relate to that kind of situation in our
youth he went through periods of great
existential crisis bouts of depression
but with sudden bursts of joy and
sadness
people in the village basically started
to think that the young nanak had lost
his mind but according to himself and
sikh how geography he was on a deep
inner spiritual search
eventually though he had a period of
relative normality when he moved to a
neighboring village got married had
children and worked as an accountant for
around 12 years during this period he
continued to be spiritually interested
and had a routine of getting up early
before sunrise bathing to purify himself
in the river and then chant and meditate
on the name of god as well as sing
devotional songs along with his muslim
friend and rabba player mardana
but one morning at the age of 33 he
suddenly never returned home from his
morning rituals people went looking for
him but couldn't find him for three days
after which he suddenly re-emerged
seemingly a changed man who had had
transformative experiences of spiritual
clarity when people asked where he had
been he simply replied through verses of
poetry or with the now famous lion quote
there is no hindu there is no muslim
what was nanak referring to here and
what was it that he had experienced
before we continue this story and in
order to understand these questions i
think it's important to get a grasp of
the cultural and religious context and
environment in which he
lived this was mughal india as many of
you have probably already gathered and
as has always been the case in india
this was a time of great religious
diversity of course the vast variety of
traditions we now collectively refer to
as hinduism was all prevalent and
nanak's families seem to have been
hindus themselves but this is also an
environment where islam was hugely
widespread and popular and especially
through the form and expression of
sufism islam sufism and hinduism had
long been in dialogue and discussion by
the time of nanak's life as we have
discussed in earlier videos there had
been many on both sides who argued for a
common core and harmony between the
muslims and caught indian monotheists
that is certain forms of hinduism
needless to say there were many at this
time including nanak who were influenced
by both the hindu and sufi traditions
and there were a lot of co-mingling
happening between these traditions
perhaps even more significantly only a
few years before the life of nanak and
sometimes contemporarily with him there
lived a group of sages or saints that
were known as the bhagats these were
local holy men deeply devoted to service
of the ineffable divine but which a lot
of the time defied any clear belonging
to one religion or the other
these included figures like the famous
kibir ravidas and nam dev and their
eclectic teachings and personality would
have a great impact on guru nanak and
sikhism as a whole
to return to our narrative nanak
returned from his three days absence an
enlightened man he had as he tells us
experienced the essential oneness of all
existence through a death of the ego
from this moment on he was given the
title of guru and began to attract an
increasing number of students
guru nanak started to dress in a way
that combined the clothing style of
hindu sadhus and muslim sufi fakhirs
which led him to often be mistaken for
one or the other and with these clothes
and together with his muslim friend and
musician mardana he started to travel
widely for a good number of years
he went eastward into the indian
subcontinent but also west all the way
to baghdad and to the holy cities of
islam mecca and medina on his travels he
would meet and discuss with
representatives of both islam hinduism
and other religious traditions by the
time he returned from these journeys he
was 50 years old and from here he
continued to grow and develop his new
community which was known as nanakpant
but which his followers would later come
to call sikhi
the teachings and instructions of guru
nanak serve as the basis for a lot of
sikh practice to this day he composed a
huge collection of devotional poetry
much of which is included in the guru
granth sahib the sacred scripture of the
sixth and which includes the center of
hymn called japi which seeks recite
every morning
nanak taught that there was only one god
a divinity that is formless and exists
in all places at all times
existence or reality is ultimately a
oneness and this oneness can be
experienced as an imminent personal
divine presence
he placed a major emphasis on the
remembrance of god's name a practice
known as nam japna where one would chant
the name waheguru or wonderful lord
much like he had done earlier in life
the sikhs were to rise early in the
morning to meditate on the name in this
way as well as to take part in kirtan
the singing of praises to god with
musical accompaniment
the purpose of these practices was to
transform the self for ego to experience
a death of the self and in that death
experience the ultimate oneness of all
things but nanak also very strictly
forbade any form of asceticism he
thought that it was very important for
the sikh followers to live a
householder's life to have a job to
provide for their family as well as to
be able to give to those who are in need
and that last point is actually another
one of the most important parts of his
teaching the importance of justice and
of helping those who are less fortunate
and connected to this guru nanak also
established what has become one of the
cornerstones of sikh practice the lankar
or free communal kitchen
this was a place where people of all
creeds and backgrounds could come and be
served a free meal in other words you
had six hindus and muslims people of
different castes nobles and peasants all
sitting shoulder to shoulder eating
together
the practice of lanka or the free
kitchen was not exactly something that
nanak came up with muslim sufis had
already done this for quite a while
before but he is unique in the sense
that he made it a cornerstone of his new
spiritual path
and this practice became such an
important part of the sikh religion that
it is still an essential part of all
gurdwaras or sikh temples to this very
day
after quite a long life and having
gathered a significant following guru
nanak passed away in the year 1539
aged 70. but before he did so he had
also established a strategy for keeping
this new path alive according to nanak
anyone could reach the level of
enlightenment that he had and become a
guru within all of us is a potential
guru a guiding principle and the key to
enlightenment known as satguru and
before he died he announced that his
leadership as guru would be carried on
by others and he appointed guru angad as
the second guru of the six
after nanak there were nine more gurus
that are acknowledged by most six making
10 gurus in total they all elaborated on
the teachings and practices of nanak in
various ways and a few of them are worth
discussing more in depth
firstly the fifth guru guru arjan is
significant in various ways he not only
expanded the sikh community greatly but
was also the one who first compiled the
scripture known as the adi grant this
was a compilation of hymns by the sikh
gurus thus far as well as other non-sikh
figures that were seen as canonical and
important quote the compilation and
installation of the adi grant was a
landmark event in sikh history
apart from putting an authoritative seal
on the poetic consciousness and
authentic teaching of the sikh gurus the
grant also provided the sikhs with its
sense of distinctness without creating
formal religious boundaries just as
importantly it signaled a change in the
outward manifestation of authority
whereas with arijan's predecessors the
body and voice of the guru had been the
sole locus of sovereign authority six
now came to recognize the grant as an
equal and legitimate form of sovereign
the adhi grant is what would later be
expanded and named the guru granth sahib
the
what you'd call the holy scripture of
the sixth but we're not quite there yet
in our story guru arjan is also
significant in that he is the one who
had the harmandir saheb better known as
the golden temple built in the city of
amritsar and established this city as a
major pilgrimage site for the sikhs
which it still is today
a lot of people think about the golden
temple when they hear the word sikhism
and this is indeed essentially the most
holy place in the world for the
practitioners of this religion
lastly guru arjan is also especially
remembered as the first martyr of the
sikh gurus
the sikh's relationship with their
muslim neighbors varied from time to
time as we saw there was a lot of mutual
respect and influence between various
religious groups in the region and the
six are part of this wider discussion
and debate at the time
the mughal rulers the emperors of the
mughal dynasty often sort of oscillated
between acceptance and tolerance and
condemnation
for example the emperor akbar is said to
have visited the early sikh community
under guru nanak
and when he visited he was so pleased
with what he saw especially the lankar
kitchen that he gave them a bunch of
gifts
which shows that akbar definitely was
positively inclined towards the six we
also see cordial relationships between
later six and figures like the prince
darashuku
and even a story where the sufi
is said to have laid the foundation
stone
at the sort of opening
of the golden temple in amritsar even if
the story is most likely a legendary it
still shows you that there was a lot of
mutual respect and interaction between
religious groups but as a war of
succession broke out between akbar's
sons salim and husro things changed
dramatically khusro had apparently
stopped by gondival during a campaign
against his brother and accounts tell
how he might have been sheltered and fed
by guru arjan and his community this of
course greatly angered salim by now the
emperor jahangir who with some stricter
islamic scholars on his side summoned
guru arajan to where he was given a
chance to either pay a fine and admit to
treason against the state or to convert
to islam when the guru refused both he
was executed by torture
this was a traumatic event for the six
and after this first martyrdom we see a
significant change in the community
the remaining five gurus would place a
much larger emphasis on defense carrying
weapons and the ideal of the warrior
saints whereas the earlier gurus had
been more pacifist and quietest
the six had become a powerful community
and would continue to grow into an
increasing threat to the mughal powers
and other rulers in the region
especially as they started to amass an
army and place a larger emphasis on
combat
now this wasn't a complete turnaround as
the earlier gurus had emphasized a
balance between spiritual practice and
purification on the one hand and an
active involvement in the world on the
other but after the martyrdom of guru
arjan and this trauma of the community
we see a
change of emphasis
by the gurus and the sikhs in a general
sense lastly i think it's important to
explore the last of the human gurus the
10th guru guru gobind singh he's central
to the story for a number of reasons
perhaps especially for the fact that he
established the khalsa this is another
turning point in the history of sikhism
one that determines the religion as we
know it today
after his father the ninth guru tegh
bahadur had also become a martyr to the
mughal emperor aurangzeb guru gobind
singh then known as gobind rai had
fortified himself and his community in
anand poor where he fought wars with a
number of hindu kings but also took time
to think about the state of the
community there had been many inner
conflicts within the sikh community
competing groups who favored different
people for the role of guru when
producing new different texts aside from
the other grant etc it was a mess and
gobindrai needed a way to bring
stability and harmony to the community
his solution to this was twofold
firstly on march the 30th 1699
he established the aforementioned khalsa
community in a theatrical ceremony that
is so fascinating that it is worth
spending some time to retell in full
the guru gathered his community of
followers in a place in anandpur where a
tent had been erected on a heightened
platform
there was excitement in the air no one
was really sure why they were there or
what was about to happen and suddenly in
the midst of this the guru comes out of
the tent with a sword in his hand
and suddenly to the shock of the
audience he asks if anyone is willing to
offer their head for the sake of the
guru at first no one answers perhaps
understandably so but after he asked
again and again finally there was a
person who stepped forward and was
willing to offer his head so the guru
took the man into the tent and the
audience heard a loud thump
and after this the guru came back out
this time with a bloodied sword
and now the guru asked again
is there anyone here who would like to
offer their head for the guru
and he continued to ask this again and
again until five people in total had
accepted gone into the tent and the
thump had been heard by the audience
the rest of the audience of course was
quite shocked and nervous i would
assume by what was happening but there
was a twist because suddenly the five
men emerged again out of the tent
seemingly unscathed and now wearing blue
and saffron robes
these five men had been given a new
exalted role quote they were introduced
to the sangha as the guru's five beloved
ones and the nucleus of the new
sovereign order called khalsa
after this the guru then officially
initiated the five men into the khalsa
order by sprinkling some sugar crystals
into an iron vessel filled with water
and then stirring that water with a
double-edged sword while reciting
certain hymns the five men then took a
drink each from this cup and now they
were formally initiated into the khalsa
they were part of this new order now
this ritual which is known as kandika
pahul
is performed to this day in the exact
same way for new initiates who wants to
become part of this khalsa community it
represents a dissolution of all former
social relations and associations no
longer with the sikhs to identify with
their caste or with their particular
family line instead all six were to take
the same last name sing for men which
means a lion and cow for women which
means princess
in other words they were now all equal
parts in a vast community of worshippers
to enter into this khalsa community
meant that you were to follow certain
rules and codes of conduct most
centrally perhaps there is often talk of
the so-called five k's now these five
symbols of sikh belonging are the same
externally for all six but there are
different interpretations within the
religion about how they should be
understood and what they all symbolize
here is one symbolic reading of the five
case the first one is called case which
is to have long unkept hair in order to
comply with the laws of nature now
related to this is also the wearing of
the sick turban which has become perhaps
the most
recognizable symbol of sikhism
secondly there is kanga which is a comb
used to well comb the hair and keep it
clean this symbolizes the sick rejection
of asceticism that while the hair is
long and allowed to grow one still takes
care of it and stays active in the world
thirdly there is kirpan a dagger that is
used to protect one's life since the
community was under threat at the time
but also as a responsibility to protect
all other life and those who are in need
of help then there is kata an iron
bracelet that represents the circle of
life and death in order to remind the
person of his mortality and thus his
responsibility to live a moral life in
accordance with the guru's teachings and
with god and lastly there is kash a kind
of undergarment that signifies a need
for sexual restraint
these 5ks now serve not only as
important aspects of sick practice on a
personal level but also serve to
distinguish these sick initiates and
more firmly establish the community's
identity the khalsa community was a new
era for the six it was the guru's
solution to the disunity of the
community and the various infightings it
consolidated the community more
concretely and established further ways
that the community distinguished
themselves
the majority of sikhs followed guru
gobind singh's new order even if some
didn't and
didn't want to give up their earlier
associations with their cast for example
still the khalsa and its characteristic
expressions is one of the cornerstones
of sikhism today and one almost cannot
be thought of without the other
but guru gobind singh wasn't done he
made another very significant change to
the sikh tradition
as a second solution to the many
problems in the community at the time he
made a drastic decision that the line of
human gurus were to end with him
instead he now established the adi grant
the texts that contained hymns by
earlier gurus and other writers as the
new eternal guru its new name the guru
granth sahib indicates its new position
the text itself was the new guru and
would continue to be so for all time
all the teachings of the 10 human gurus
were collected in this work and it was
to serve as the primary source of
guidance for sikhs from then on thus
with the death of guru gobind singh in
1708 the era of the human sikh gurus
ends and the era of the guru granth
sahib begins
from then on authority was shifted from
the line of gurus to the guru granth
sahib as well as the guru khalsa pant
the khalsa community of initiates itself
the guru granth sahib is a massive
compendium it is still at the very
center of sikh practice today
all gurudwaras sikh temples contain a
copy of it indeed having a copy of the
text is what makes a place a gurvara at
least one of the things by the time of
the 10th guru's death we're not that far
back in history anymore but of course in
spite of this since then sikhism has
continued to evolve and change to meet
new times and situations
developments like modernity and
colonialism has of course forced sikhs
to re-evaluate and re-understand certain
aspects of their religion and as with
all religions it is a tradition that is
constantly
evolving and changing with time and
circumstance indeed as we saw in the
beginning it was due to the colonialists
and their categorizations that the whole
concept of a sikhism as a religion in
the western sense even came to be and
very significant political changes like
the independence of india in 1947 of
course has played a major role in the
way that sikhism has evolved and the way
that it functions today
okay so with all of this history in mind
we can now start to explore more in
depth the actual beliefs and teachings
of sikhism the philosophy of sikhism if
you will as well as how all of that
relates to the historical events that we
have been talking about
the teachings and ideas of sikhism are
very interesting and fascinating
especially in relation to
the context and environment in which it
originated
it is born in an environment where islam
especially as understood through sufism
and hinduism are in dialogue
and the teachings of the sikh gurus can
definitely appear to have features from
both of these traditions and especially
exist at the very meeting points between
the two religions in those places where
the similarities between them kind of
co-mingle remember when guru nanak came
back from his transformative spiritual
experience he uttered the very famous
quotes there is no hindu there is no
muslim seemingly indicating that he
wanted to find or indicate some sort of
truth that hides within both of those
traditions and to do away with sectarian
identification with either of the two
that's at least one interpretation of
what he means firstly sikhism is usually
referred to as a monotheistic religion
this means that they believe in the
existence of a single god or put less
abrahamically a singular divine
principle
this divinity is known by the term
ikonkar a complex phrase that can be
translated in many ways as one god as
there is only one god sometimes all is
one or in a more literal translation one
whose expression emerges as word
the important part as you can tell is
the word ich which is literally the
number one
the divine is one and oneness is the
absolute
guru nanak and his successors taught
that the sought-after absolute
experience is one where all of reality
is realized to be a single oneness or a
non-duality that oneness being an
intimate presence and identical with god
this idea of god also sometimes called
waheguru wondrous teacher is expressed
in the very first lines of the japji
guru nanak's most central composition
that is recited every morning by six the
first lines of this hymn has become a
kind of creedal statement and is known
as mulmantar and goes quote there is one
supreme being the eternal reality the
creator without fear and devoid of
enmity immortal never incarnated
self-existent known by grace through the
true guru
the goal according to nanak and the
other gurus is to realize this inherent
oneness of reality the divine that is
always present and available to everyone
god 2d6 is an all-embracing reality it
exists everywhere at all times in all
things and yet somehow transcendent from
them at the same time
one can achieve this goal through the
teachings of the human and scriptural
gurus of course but it is an experience
that is essentially available to
everyone we all have the potential for
enlightenment within us a principle
referred to as sat guru or true guru
that can unlock a unitive experience
satguru is quite simply the force
imminent within us that creates a change
of conversion from ordinary ego centered
consciousness to ego-less consciousness
and that's precisely the point what is
it that's keeping us from realizing this
essential oneness at all times if it is
always present within us in simple terms
it's the ego the very concept of the i
with which we usually identify ourselves
this is the main obstacle against
knowing god because when we say i we
identify ourselves as a thing in
opposition to other things so that's
we're creating a duality if there is an
i that means there is something other
than myself and thus we have created a
duality which goes against the very
nature of god which is that all things
are a oneness so the more we create
duality the more we identify with this
ego this i the less we can know god and
the one as such
this gets in the way of us realizing
that there is no i at least if
understood as being different from other
things because all things are one guru
nanak says quote o nanak to recognize
this imperative for it to take effect
let the ego not say i am myself
a very simple instruction it seems but
it is of course a little more
complicated than that but this is
essentially the crux of the problem
where there is i
or ego there cannot be god the very
nature and experience of god as oneness
is fundamentally incompatible with the
experience of an individual self this is
expressed by guru nanak and the other
gurus in the guru granth sahib and is
one of the main themes that has hammered
home again and again
god and the self can never be in the
same place at the same time so to say
for example listen to this verse quote
when i act an ego you're not present
when you're present ego is absent o
nanak repeat these words he is me i am
him the one in whom the three worlds are
merged
the person who has reached this
sovereign consciousness is referred to
as a gurmukh to be in character or
personality of a guru
as opposed to a manmook someone who
follows his ego or lower mind but as
opposed to the teachings of some more
extremely ascetical traditions sikhi
doesn't teach that one is to annihilate
the ego as such the ego or one's
consciousness has to be rewired by
reciting the name of god and one
transforms one's understanding from i am
myself to i am not but at the same time
the gurus were very adamant that the
sikh practitioners needs to be active in
this world to live a social life be a
householder and provide for one's family
and those around you sikhism rejects
asceticism but teaches that the
transformed ego or self-understanding is
to be reoriented to a care and concern
for the well-being of others one is to
stay away from evil vices and tendencies
in particular there is often talk of the
so-called five enemies five moral evils
there are to be avoided and fought by
all six
these are one calm which is lust or
craving two crowd anger
three lobe greed
there is more attachment and a
egotism
it is for this reason that seeks plays a
major emphasis on helping others and on
charity practices that we have already
mentioned like the lanka or communal
kitchen has been a central part of sikhi
because of this
now aside from some of these basic
themes and teachings sikhi also teaches
some things that we recognize from other
religious traditions like hinduism
buddhism and jainism the sikhs believe
in a version of reincarnation that when
we die we are then reborn
perhaps the most central practice of
sikhism the primary way that one is to
change one's consciousness and silence
the ego is by reciting the name of god a
practice known as nam japani here the
name of god specifically the name
waheguru is chanted for a duration of
time it is thought that by remembering
god's name by reciting god's name again
and again one rewires the ego to stop
identifying with the self and instead
realizing
a kind of divine consciousness or
understanding or becoming more conscious
of the oneness of reality which is after
all what god is another very central
part of sikh practice is the performance
of kirtan in other words of music and
singing
from the days of guru nanak who would be
accompanied in his own singing on the
rabbah by his muslim companion maradana
the performance of music is one of the
cornerstones of sikh practice so if you
visit a gurvara or you go to a sikh
ceremony there will usually be music
involved they will sing the hymns from
the guru granth sahib
and praise god through musical form this
is very important all of these practices
can be done basically anywhere but there
are also sikh places of worship known as
gurudwara meaning a door to the guru in
which devotees gather for communal
services
a gurdwara must house a copy of the guru
granth sahib the sacred scripture of
sikhism which figures at the centerpiece
of the temple anne of the ceremony the
book will often be treated like a human
guru seated on a kind of throne and
given the utmost respect and care when
being recited there will usually be
attendants who will wave fans in the
same way that one would traditionally
treat kings as you probably remember the
guru granth sahib is considered to be
the everlasting guru the successor to
the 10 human gurus and contains the
hymns and composition of those earlier
human gurus as well as other writers
it is quite significant that the guru
grant sahib is one of the rare
scriptures that actually include
writings by people from other religions
in the guru granth sahib we find poems
and hymns from hindus sufi muslims like
baba fareed as well as figures who are
harder to pin down as such like kabir
reciting the hymns from the guru granth
sahib is another key feature of the life
of sikhs a gurdwara can really be any
kind of building as long as it contains
the text
everything from a regular living room to
the most famous and very ornate golden
temple in amritsar india gurdwaras are
usually open to anyone who wants to
visit regardless of religious
affiliation and they almost always have
a lanka or communal kitchen connected to
them it is also in gurdwaras that
important life events like name giving
ceremonies and marriages are performed
however with all of this said it is
important to keep in mind rule number
one when it comes to studying and
understanding religions that all
religions are internally diverse and
that they change and evolve over time
this means that
anything that i've said in this video
regarding the beliefs and
interpretations of sikh ideas is
just that it's one interpretation and
there's usually a lot of different
groups and understandings within the
religion itself as in any other religion
for example as we saw earlier not all
six initially accepted the new order
initiated by guru gobind singh the
council community
and as such did not choose to adhere to
the 5ks for example in other words it
goes without saying that not all six
have long hair or
you know not all six wear turbans like
all religions sikhism is a complex and
multifaceted tradition today sikhi is a
religious tradition with the presence in
many parts of the world
the main center where the majority of
sikhs live is still in india and
especially in the punjab region where it
originated it is estimated that there
are around 22 million six living in
india today
but over the last centuries there has
also formed significant diaspora
communities especially in places like
the united kingdom canada and the united
states
wherever sikhs are found they are often
very active and visible participants in
society for example the former canadian
minister of national defense harjit
singh sajan is a sikh and served between
2015-2021
in total there are around 25 million six
in the world today making it one of the
largest religions in the world often
ranked as the fifth largest right after
buddhism
and by now i hope that some of you feel
a little more enlightened and
comfortable in your understanding of
this major religion of the world it is a
very young religion especially compared
to many of the other major religions but
it is one that has established itself
very quickly as a cornerstone not only
of religious history in india but of the
entire world sikhism began with the life
and teachings of guru nanak in the 16th
century and has continued to grow and
evolve until today what remains a deep
and rich tradition that can easily
inspire
and fascinate anyone who is lucky enough
to explore it
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you